this is my impression to every company
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
okay whoa whoa never mind
that's every company now
whoa whoa whoa we didn't realize you
were gonna get that pissed off at this
never mind
only fans well the bankers and the uh
people who buy our you know uh who who
fund us are uh they don't want nudity on
only fans anymore now here's the hacky
joke but I have to say it since this is
this podcast and we talk about
everything but only fans
that's what you do
that's like McDonald's McDonald's
getting rid of
this is hacky but you gotta say that's
like McDonald's getting rid of
cheeseburgers and [__] coca-colas
acts like McDonald's getting rid of
cancer that's like what they're doing
That's like [__] J crew getting rid
of sweaters that only your dad would buy
and your uncle
J crew getting rid of [__] v-necks uh
v-neck uh Cashmere
light green sweaters that's what that is
that's like Canon getting rid of cameras
that's like what that's like Dude
lenses
that's like a home builder not showing
up one day and been like why are you
relying on me to build your house that's
what that is
That's like [__] New Era saying go
bald
that's what that's saying
show sport your baldness that's what
that's that's what that's like
that's like the MLB going what bats
that's what that's like
that's like Kleenex saying you know
what's really cool blow and snot out all
over your mouth and walking around town
that's what that's like
that's like sock makers saying hey where
Davis
that's what that's like
that's like hairdressers saying why we
love the caveman look that's what that's
like
that's what that's like
that's like politicians saying hey
trust us
that's what that's like
so what that's like
that's like Radio Shack saying we didn't
exist only in the 80s and are still
trying to do our thing
that's what that's like
SWAT that's like
that's like Trojans saying
splurtner
have kids
that's what that's like
SWAT that's like
you know what I'm saying dude
that's like Smith and Wesson saying
build the slingshot
that's what that's like
okay
SWAT that's like
you understand
that's like Home Depot saying
don't hire the Mexicans outside of our
place
so what that's like okay that's what
that's like that's like Oakley saying
where us even if you don't have chapped
lips
SWAT ass lack
so what that's like that's like [__]
whoever makes those Carnation shorts
saying Hey by us even if your dad isn't
a lawyer on Cape Cod SWAT ass like
okay so what that's like
you understand what I'm saying
that's like the [__] guys who made
the [__] you know dick trimmers
what's the [__] dick the pube trimmer
shits they used to [__] do our ads
what are those guys that's like them
saying hey we're not trying to be quirky
and jump on a trend SWAT that slag
that's what's like meandi saying hey
no more patterns SWAT that's like I got
me undies with [__] soy sauce on it
and I don't mean I spelled it on it
I mean that's the bread SWAT ass like
SWAT ass like
okay
that's like me going to the gym getting
a membership at equinox or 24 Hour
Fitness and saying you know what I'm
just gonna work out my mouth and talk to
everybody who's on the treadmill from
now on SWAT that Sly SWAT ass lie
that's like me Ben that's like Kevin
Costner shows up in a movie and halfway
through he says to Whitney Houston You
know what you'll take the bullets and he
drives home and goes to Shakey's SWAT
ass like swadders like that's like shaky
saying go to McDonald's
that's what it's like
you know what I'm saying
it's like Twitter's saying you was
parlor it's like parlors saying
use whatever the [__] new one that
Trump is gonna make you know
and it's like the new one that Trump's
gonna make it's like saying it's like
they're saying use telegram so what does
hey what the [__] is telegram by the way
is it texted or Not My Buddy lost his
mind he's on telegram anyone who loses
their mind goes on telegram telegram
what are ya
telegram what are you I never know no
matter how many people explained it to
me
uh what do you want dude
only fans dude
no I'm at you know that's one of those
things that I imagine somebody was just
like you know what that idea is just so
crazy it might work
[Laughter]
dude
it's like Little Debbie saying what
snacks swap the Slime swap the slide
it's like hindsen eat it dry Squad ass
lag
swab ass lie
I mean what the [__] dude and then they
were like never mind
only fans [__] sucks now I was on
board with only fans
I was signed up to Tyga's account no I
wasn't I'm kidding but that would be
hilarious I gotta sign up to Tyga's
account on only fans I gotta get on only
fans and only show shots of me and jeans
that would be so ill dude
just me and jeans I need and only fans
where I just promise you every week a
new picture of me and only jeans dude
I need a new app called only jeans that
you can sign up for and you put out you
in only jeans and we do not discriminate
dude we have Asians and whites and
blacks and Indians and even people from
Croatia with all with accounts and
they've got only jeans on men women it
doesn't matter dude you could be a small
person a large person you could be
totally [__] the only requirement we
have is you only have jeans on and it's
only jeans
you can't wear [__] and then another one
a sister app we need only Blazers and
that's all you wear dude just Blazers
and everyone has a gun you can be a
famous [__] person you come out here
you just wear a blazer now that's where
your dicks and [__] are out and
that's fine but only jeans your dicks
and your [__] are inside of your
jeans but whatever's on your chest that
shit's out dude
own the jeans and only Blazers
that doesn't only Blazers doesn't really
have a a ring to it like only jeans but
[__] man you can make a million dollars
on only jeans